- Les combats ont pris finssssss
ici. Les ruines fument toujours
et les champs continuent
de brûler.
Si ce n'était umumumumumumumumut
des voitures marqués du Z,
symbole de l'armée russe ici,
des restes de projectiles
et m
le sol, on devinerait mal
les combats des derniers jours.
Le capitaine Yaroshenko
de la 60e brigade assure
"Ils ont fait preuve de courage
ici. Ils ont tenu jusqu'au bout,
a été de briser leur première
ligne de défense, mais, apr
on les a juste pourchassés
alors qu'ils se sauvaient
sur 30 kilomètres."
Ils ont profité du t
pluvieux pour surprendre
l'ennemie, dit-il,
Maestro, Psycho, Zolotnyi
et Khrame, leur nom de code,
font partie d'une unité
reconnaissance du 98e bataillon
de la 60e brigade.
Leur tâche : in
les positions russes
pour identifier des cibles.
"Nous sommes toujoursMaMaMaMaMa.
Alors, souvent, on passe aussi
à l'assaut. Ce n'est pas
que de la reconnaissance."
Quand on leur demande
ce qu'ils ont sacrifiée e e e e,
ils se taisent et baissent
le regard. Ils ont perdu
six de leurs compagnons d'armes
offensive dans le sud.
"Quand tu avances, tu ne
te dis pas que c'est difficile,
dit le soldat. Tu sais que
des enfa q q que des vieillards
sont derrière toi, et quand
tu libères un village v v v v vs
ressentent. Ça justifie tout."
Dans plus d'une vingtaine
de villages maintenant libérés
de l'occupation russe,
du soulagement à l'incrédulité,
en passant par la haine.
Celle de ceux qui ont imposé
Il n'y a pas que les maisons
qui sont détruites, les gens
Il raconte avoir été emprisonné
et tor d d dans sa propre cave
par des soldats russes pendant
trois semaines en "Ils m'ont bas
je ne sentais plus la douleur,
raconte l'homme, peut-être
à cause de l'adrénaline.LeLeLeLe
brisaienycycychologiquement."
Après ces trois semaines à être
geôliers s'en sont désintéressés
et sont partis plus loin.
Il a fui K
dans un convoi humanitaire
à la première occasion.
Si lui est revenu av
des soldats ukrainiens,
Tetyana et Olha, elles,
en ont profité
Les deux voisines ont sauté sur
les premiers soldats ukrainiens
venus. Ils les ont conduit
le visage rongé par les piqûres
de moustiques, dans un centre
d'hébergement à Kryvyï Rih,
Pe
les huit derniers mois passés,
avec la rage au coeu l l la faim
au ventre, Maksim, son fils,
se prend la tête sans arrêt.ssss
le choc des bombardements.
Enfermé dans son cauchemar,
tout est devenu agression
pour lui. Il"A"A"A"A"A"A"A"A"A",
il a arrêté de parler, raconte
Olha. Il bégayait un peu,
il a peur de tout maintenant.
il a peur. S'il y a beaucoup
de m, , , il a peur.
Nos militaires, il en a peur.
Il ne comprend pas que ceux-
Les repas chauds et les soins
que les femmes reçoivent, enfin,
ne les empêchent pas d'avoir
laissé au village, de ceux
qui n'ont pas pu les suivre.
"Nous prions pour retourner.
Je ne peux pas voir mon enfa
dit Tetyana. Ma plus vieille est
comme ce garçon, mais elle est
chez mes parents. Ils vi
l'autre côté du pont qui a été
détruit. Je ne peux pas y aller.
Je l'ai vue par in
première fois en sept mois hier.
Je ne savais pas quoi lui dire."
Les blessure
à leurs familles, les jeunes
femmes ne les pardonnent pas.
Elles on
qui les a menées jusqu'ici
avec un jeune conscrit russe,
prison
qui les conduisaient.
Soudainement désarmé,
fragile. Olhena n'avait qu'une
envie, lui crever les yeux.
puissante et qu'ils allaient
prendre tout ce qu'ils
notre petite armée les a battus.
Quand ils ont commencé à fuir,
des gens comme nous,ntntntntntnà
les attraper, à les empoisonner,
à les battre."
Un patriote, c'est comme ça
que se décrit Nikita. C'ueueueue
s'est joint à l'armée.
Il est au front depuis
une semaine à peine.
On lui a enseigné l'aripipipipi,
il se retrouve sur le champ
de bataille armé d'un fusil.
"Si j'arrive à voler
de l'artillerie aux êêêêêêêêêêê,
mais pour l'instant, je suis
dans l'infanterie. On le dit
souvent à la blague, mais
c'est une blague quie e e e e e"
La semaine a été éprouvante :
trop de bris d'équipement
désuet, trop de blessés
inutiles.mpmpmpmpmpmpmpmpmpmpmp"
Tant qu'il garde le moral,
l'impossible, croit-il,
restera à portée de son arme.